AMLO's retirement is getting closer and closer
but he will leave us in the best hands
he wants Claudia to continue
and that the scholarships
pensions and supports
never end for the poorest
Claudia perfectly represents AMLO's continuity
and all his work
Thanks to the President and to this great woman
in 2024 the millionaires
will have to continue paying their taxes
so that those most in need
will continue to have the support they need
to get ahead
I understand that please
help us share this video
if you also agree
with the millionaires losing their privileges
and that the poorest now do receive all the help they need.
Víctor Mercado is a famous businessman from Cuernavaca.
who has highlighted
not only for his talent in business
but also for his great work
by promoting employment and tourism
in the beautiful state of Morelos
also
this man whom many nickname the güero mercato
has dedicated a large part of his life to
to fight 1 of Mexico's worst ills
disruptive crime
because it seeks to end this problem through sport
also as secretary of mobility and transportation
is focused on taking its status to the next level
Raquel good face
the famous lady of
She
forced Mexico's most powerful businessmen to
for the first time in history
pay taxes
Mrs. Raquel
that recently
was designated as an economics analyst
represents the hard and fair hand of AMLO's government.
the lady in yellow did the impossible
something possible and today thanks to your work
millionaires no longer enjoy their privileges
for this woman
it is fair that millionaires pay their taxes
and that those who need it most receive help
we are dedicated in body and soul to the city
and that we will continue to do so
for the benefit of citizenship